we had these three concepts and they
were very very closely connected if you
remember so you don't need to write this
down because you've got in your books
already but I just want to refer to them
what are these things
we start with limit of reading if I told
you for instance then I had measured say
I don't know the the height of Garry
time okay and I'd said it was like okay
you don't know anything else about that
okay I've got at the moment based on
that number without any other
information you actually know the limit
of reading already right what's the
limit of reading on this thing it's
gonna be a centimeter right so therefore
because I'm not sure if this this could
be a majesty 0.2 or hundred sixty seven
point six or something like that
therefore I've got an error that comes
along for the road right how do I get
the error from the limit of range
it's halfway right because we can always
sort of round up you could run down but
if all you've got is to the nearest
centimeter that's what you've got so
this is like the smallest year and this
is half obvious okay so far so good
therefore if we talked about that as the
hype there are actually like what we
imply by saying hundred sixty eight
centimeters is actually a range right
what's the shortest he could possibly be
for me to still have been 168
centimeters yeah fine because any less
than that just seven point four and I
would have rounded down make sense
that's going to be less than or equal to
just hi what's the largest his heart
could possibly be that I was still
measurements
good see you're taking the absolute the
arrow and you're just going plus or
minus does that make sense
so we're saying actually no no because
because if I yeah like I see what you
meet here what what I'm thinking that is
this is an arrow right it comes from an
arrow and it really could have been like
right on that line and I still said no
it's closer again this is like the
limitations of its the whole point of
not being able to read this and knowing
with a hundred signatures
okay now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take these three concepts and
we're just gonna push in them a little
wall you might never remember it in
excess to eight I sound like a hot issue
it's a warm exercise so I'm gonna cook
you now there's two important things we
want to point concepts we will get
across that will let you do the second
half of this exercise so would you make
a little subheading which is percentage
error let me try and contrast this
remember I said to you there's
absolutely error before so that let's
based on like centimeters or meters or
kilometers or programs or whatever unit
you're willing so a percentage error it
takes that and says just compare it and
we'll take Gary's are integers by me and
just compare it to what actually to us
you've got this so is this gonna make
not centimeters or meters what we need
to do with those units it'll just be a
Dumbo with a percentage alone for right
okay so you remember here we said the
absolute error so this is an example the
absolute error was half a centimeter
right okay now what did I actually
measure as its height its 168
centimeters so what I'm asking is what
is the absolute edible as a part of the
actual thing
so if I want the percentage are out of
this
therefore the percentage error I take
the absolute out I'm just gonna
abbreviate that because I'm secure I'm
heading that and I'm gonna divide it by
whatever it was that I mentioned the
actual measurement okay now in this case
the actual numbers are gonna look like
this 0.5 that's what you guys told me in
the beginning half of them a bit of
reading divided by 168 so I reach for
their calculator and tell me that should
hand you a decimal and I actually do
want the decimal I'm not gonna get my
calculator out faster than you guys
feels they're right you should be me not
ha hilarious this give you to scientific
notation I didn't expect that it would
do that yes yeah my doesn't obviously we
talked to this before the TV setup okay
I did beat you okay here's what is
here's my guess is your point
okay now what I've got here this is a
decimal so I want to convert this to a
percentage right so I'm gonna multiply
by a hundred percent so when I multiply
by 100 how far in the decimal place
gonna go it's gonna move two spots right
so this becomes zero point two nine
seven six percent right so what's my
actual percentage error here I can round
this off however I choose but remember
we've been thinking about error here
right
I've got a whole lot of significant fees
there how many significant fee is do you
think would be appropriate I've written
down for that was
okay I'm going to round this off I'm
actually going to round it to two
decimal places now we're gonna talk a
little bit more about this in detail
later on but what I want to point out to
you like where did I fashioned that
number from remember like where'd all
these decimal places come from they come
from these measurements right but
they're not exact
yeah how many significant figures do I
have what what area is actually sort of
part of this I don't have like millions
and millions of decimal places see that
are meaningful to me all right this is
an arrow okay so all I want to point out
to you is I'm going to approximate I'll
just go say that to two decimal places
now this is useful because if we said to
you on the absolute error on measuring
something was say Amina okay so just
throw that out for some reason you don't
know what the measurement is okay now if
I centimeter you don't know if that's a
really accurate measurement or really
inaccurate measurement if I said to you
I know Gary's height within one meter
that's pretty poor or anything it's like
a lumpy around two meters that's very
very inaccurate on the other hand if I
told you I know the circumference of the
earth so the limit of one meter that is
super accurate right now I'm depending
on like if my absolute error is one
meter over his height which is one point
six eight meters okay that's a huge
percentage I don't even know what that
number is but I assume that 60 percent
so it's like whoa
that's an enormous number whereas I
figure out what I mentioned this is
comfort to the element that if I said
one meter over its like thousands of
kilometers actually don't think it's six
or nine thousand ish okay this numbers
going to be tiny
do you agree like zero point zero zero
zero zero however many number of decimal
places after here and then you might get
like a one okay so this is super
accurate and this is really lousy okay
can someone how many does it get to a
site to be okay did you do any meters of
kilometers because I need more zeros
here right okay it's beside my point
what I'm trying to get across is
percentage error that gives you
something much more meaningful than
absolute error and that's why it kind of
takes a little more work to actually